[Music]
look
the only court packing going on right
now
is going on with republicans attacking
the court now
it's not constitutional what they're
doing we should be focused on what's
happening
right now and the fact is that the only
packing going on
is this court is being packed now by the
republicans
after the vote has already begun i'm
going to stay focused on it so we don't
take the eyes off the ball here
well look um
i before i came out again today to go
somewhere i had another test
this morning and i'm clear i think it's
important the president
make sure two things one that he
is clear he is not a spreader
like his like dr fauci said the super
spreader event he had for the supreme
court
about announcement and secondly i think
it's important that he make it clear to
all the people
that they should be socially distanced
they should be on the lawn that's fine
but in fact they should be socially
distant and wearing masks
that's the only responsible thing to do
and i don't know what's going on at the
moment now but i hope he does that
thank